I think it's more women that don't give
men access to their children I think
it's a mix I I don't know what promotion
but I think there's both right like yeah
I think there's way more women that
don't let men see their children than
vice versa that's my opinion why'd you
think that PO can I ask um it's just
from interviewing guys like I'm doing a
documentary on divorce and you would
just be shocked by how many men there
are in this country that want to see
their children so bad so I actually know
something I will like cry why don't they
fight for Access
I'll tell you why it's because one phone
call a woman can ruin a man's life it
just takes one phone call so essentially
what a girl can do is if I'm dating
someone right and we have a kid together
I can make one phone call accuse him of
um get a restraining order against him
with basically no evidence get him
arrested and then you are incentivized
to do that because you get a free lawyer
in divorce court
so now you go to divorce court and the
the crazy thing is especially when covet
happened it took a lot a lot of um the
cases that I've looked at took one to
two years to actually happen so in that
time period he doesn't have access to
his kids and then um he has to pay child
support in the time and the and the time
being a lot of the guys were kicked out
of their houses and every and he's known
by everyone as an abuser again this is
all with no evidence because in family
court it's not based on evidence it's
based on a balance of probabilities so
so it's not in Criminal Court this is
Family Court
um and so basically uh it's so sad it's
like literally the saddest thing these
guys will live like a mile from their
kids and they don't have access to them
they can't see them I know one guy that
went through Court to see his kid and he
lost so much weight he couldn't eat he
was depressed because his his uh misses
well he wasn't he wasn't married but his
girlfriend took the child away but I
know a lot of guys and that was just one
I know so much women that have got waste
man baby fathers and I think they both
exist but the ratio is nowhere near even
this is what I think I think there's two
things that go on one women do make bad
reproductive choices in my opinion where
they they reproduce with a guy that
clearly is a bad pick toxic like abusive
control like whatever whatever they'll
say right
um but I I do think that the second
thing going on is we only hear the
woman's side and I think we have an
innate like proclivity to just believe
women when they tell us things and I
think a lot of times if you heard the
man's point of view like I know know
someone that like is literally
destroying like a man's reputation on
social media and the husband reached
like saying he's a deadbeat dad he left
all the stuff the husband reaches out
and says that she left with the kid and
she hasn't had access to him or he
hasn't had access now who who's right
who's wrong right we don't actually know
yeah but but I will tell you it is a lot
more common than people think that men
want to see their children and the women
will not give them access out of spite I
don't personally and I'd not disagree
with you I know they exist I don't
personally know any women like that nor
disputing they exist however I think the
ratio is not as as much I think the
ratio is much larger that women are
trying to get help from their baby
fathers they're trying to get financial
help they're trying to get emotional
help physical help looking after the
kids so that she can have a little life
of her own social life you know before
she's an old woman with cats you know I
mean she might want to date it's okay
for him to get a girlfriend she can't
get it next man you know it's a lot of
double standards you know I think I
think if that were true then more women
women would let men have 50 50 custody
no no it's not true it's again men only
get access 10 percent of the time do you
realize how small of a number that is 10
like they're correct we can agree
they're shitty moms they're shitty dads
but 10 who who
um
sometimes what the what the left will do
is they'll say why don't these men fight
for custody so I'm going to go back to
that story one phone call this woman
calls the police the whole Community
thinks he's an abuser okay now he's lost
his reputation he's lost his friends a
lot of these men go so crazy they lose
their jobs now by the time they get to
court the court says why haven't you
been in the kid's life for a year and a
half and the woman there's no
consequence for keeping the man from his
kids there will be a consequences when
the kids grow up it's when like you're
right it's when the kids grow older but
they also don't talk about parental
alienation and I mean we have examples
of celebrities that this happened in
front of our eyes like think of Kanye
Kanye loved his mom comes to find out
his mom that he loved right right he was
on her side had never had took him out
of I think it was Atlanta or like some
somewhere down south and took him to
Chicago without the father's consent and
I've interviewed guy after guy after Guy
where a lot of times the woman will
leave the state or leave the country and
he gets a no say and so a lot of guys
don't fight because they see all their
friends getting screwed in divorce court
because and I've even talked to divorce
lawyers about this it's like when a man
when a woman has a kid that is not your
kid it's hers because if you go to court
and you want to spend so now he's been
paying child support for a year
sometimes a year and a half he goes to
court and now he has to pay lawyer fees
to maybe get the kid for a 10 chance are
you going to do that a lot of guys just
say screw it I have no say and the rest
of my life I access to my child is
dependent on how she feels because the
other thing is women can do the same
process he could win maybe get 50 50
custody which he probably won't she'll
still probably get primary custody
because she's been the primary caregiver
for the last year so she'll still
probably get it they don't ask why and
the crazy thing is
she can do it again
so like I'll talk to guys they got close
to 50 50 custody like maybe they'll get
three days a week or two days a week and
they're happy with that then she he does
something she doesn't like boom she
calls the cops again I even I have seen
text messages of the woman trying to get
the husband to hit her saying I wish he
would just hit me
and and they literally in court they
didn't care she still got primary
custody how crazy is that I'm telling
you this is so common like this is the
number one dm I do not get any more DMS
than about this documentary
so the way that men can be proactive in
this case is to seek legal
representation first which is there is a
benefit to seeking food but I'll tell
you I'll tell you the problem is a lot
of guys don't see this coming because
the women they can go to their doctor
and start this process and they can go
to women's shelters there's like nine
women's shelters for every one men's
shelter there are not men's shelters
like that so women go to the women's
shelter and what they do there is they
give them a whole story to tell them
about
um the the father of their children and
this could you know this could just be
hearsay but I've heard this from so many
different guys where they go to the
women's shelter and they'll say okay
he's Nigerian you have to say this about
him he's Eastern European you have to
say this about them like a certain story
based on their culture
I've had
no I don't even think it's sociopathic I
just think women have so much power in
this regard and I I think like okay if
we we take female evil right what's
female evil it's spite like women can be
very manipulative and very spiteful
what's male evil aggression right like
they kill someone they get angry and so
it's like okay if we legally gave men
guns when they were at their angriest
what would they do they would kill more
when we legally give women the tools to
destroy a man's life they're going to do
it more because it's legal because they
can and the women's shelters make this
all possible and when you follow the
money they all like the lawyers um the
number one the lawyers have no incentive
to even help the men because who's the
lawyer's number one client
mothers so if you win too many cases
you're not going to be recommended
that's the number one client from the
lawyer like all of the money it follow
like it's a whole system I feel like I
feel like it's all extremely sad very
very very sad and there's conversations
sad I mean even criminals can get
supervised visitors
pretty bad can I just finish there is so
many kids that are suffering so many
that I'm seeing in my family
friends like it's sad like listen to
what we're talking about it's sad it's
they're just bringing children into this
world
and the child and we're talking about
the fight between the mum and the dad
and it's crazy and then you've got these
children these poor little children
who I'm thinking of like some of my
friends
are struggling because he's manipulative
she's manipulative and you've got this
kid who is just a kid and just wants to
be a kid and doesn't want to have to go
through all of this crap
and I think it all comes down to
promiscuous promise like being if we was
taught right if we was taught right
because it's not right to sleep around
it's not right to to just be like Oh I'm
just gonna get an abortion it's not and
even if you are live pro-life pro-choice
you know even pro-choice you know it's
not right to be like let's get another
version as getting over abortion I'll
get another one it's not right these and
it is a life and I get that some people
don't believe that it is a life it's got
a heartbeat you go to a scan the amount
of women that I know that I've been like
I'm pregnant how do they know like and
then they've gone on the phone and they
are they knew they got pregnant on this
certain day like it's it's something
spiritual it's something that we cannot
explain no science can explain it no
like how can we explain a life a woman
create in life we create life that is
that that is the most amazing thing in
the world like man and a woman get
together and they can't I think you're
what I think it's this is just it's
really sad I I totally agree with you I
think you bring bring brought out a very
important point it's responsibility you
know you mentioned that it's you it's
your response it's our responsibility to
uh give out the birth but it's also
think about this if you are now you're
homeless and you have you carry a baby
but you you can uh you mentalize
unstable and you can't even afford to
raise a baby think about you don't want
to raise it you know well my mom was in
that situation my mom gave up um she she
had a kid um she gave up a kid for
adoption when she was 17. and it's
actually really cool he grew up um I met
him when I was 22 for the first time
he's 31 he just got married he just had
his first son
so I mean a lot of times we act like if
you're in a bad situation there's no
light at the end of the tunnel there's
nothing you can do but you know adoption
is really a great option for people that
aren't in a situation to have children
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis
form if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible